one of the reasons i've been telling you
that it's unclear
that the trump riots will have much of
an impact on american politics going
forward
is that many americans either won't
remember what happened on january 6th
or will remember it but fall for lies
about what it was that took place and
believe something that's a complete
fantasy
we now have evidence that this is
happening there is a new
reuters ipsos poll released yesterday
which found
look at this half of republicans
believe that the trump riots were
left-wing activists merely trying to
make trump look bad
or largely non-violent protests
neither of those assertions is true
three in ten republicans believe that
trump is partially responsible for the
riots
seven and ten do not sixty percent of
republicans
believe that donald trump's uh believe
trump's lies
that the 2020 election was stolen 60
percent
60 percent of republicans believe that
donald trump
should run in 2024 and
80 percent of republicans have favorable
opinions of
trump many important things to note
number one i said yesterday it would be
irresponsible for a show about american
politics to ignore donald trump right
now
partially because he still is uh the
face of the republican party overall
this poll again comes confirms that
sixty percent want him running in in
three two
four years three to four years eighty
percent still view him favorably
sixty percent believe his lies that he
actually was the rightful winner of
2020. so
again that is born out number two
this doesn't suggest that trump and
republicans are going to be held
accountable
in 2022. uh maybe in 2022
they will be held accountable for other
things things that haven't yet happened
things that will be more
fresh and recent in the minds of
republican voters but there is
no evidence whatsoever that the trump
riots
and the way that republicans defended it
are going to have any serious impact on
2022
but the voters either either don't
believe it um or they've forgotten
or whatever um as i mentioned
very much the party of trump they also
claim to be the party of personal
responsibility
but they take no responsibility and
assign no responsibility or blame to
their own elected officials ever
ever i was kind of stepping back as i
was reading these
poll numbers and considering the
absurdity of the situation
remember that donald trump lost the
popular vote by millions
in 2016. he accomplished essentially
zero of his campaign promises
he was going to pay off the debt he
didn't do it he was going to build a
wall across the u.s mexico border he
didn't do it he was going to replace
obamacare with something beautiful he
didn't do it
he was going to fix trade he didn't do
it i could give you the whole list
never had an approval rating over 50 the
only president in the polling era
never to reach 50 approval even on a
single day during their presidency
and then he had the pandemic come in
which for
uh world leaders that handled it well
was a ticket to an easy re-election
trump mismanaged the pandemic leading to
countless extra unnecessary deaths
and then republicans say oh clearly it's
not believable that trump lost
what trump did everything wrong
had a disastrous approval and mismanaged
the pandemic
why would you assume he's obviously
going to win why would you assume joe
biden somehow stole it
of course trump lost and the real shock
is
how didn't trump lose by more trump
still almost
won electorally despite the fact
that he mishandled all of those things
the real tragedy
is that despite everything trump failed
on
75 million people still voted for him so
anybody waiting around for you know the
consequences of what the republican
party and trump became and what they did
and
in 2022 it's not going to happen if they
do something
disastrous in august of 2022
then let's talk but as i've said before
republicans don't even know what's going
on
in general voters have short political
memories
and we're seeing that borne out already
it's only april of 2021.
and more than half of republican voters
don't even understand
and or refuse to believe what it was
that even happened in january
of this year let's take a quick break
let me know your thoughts about
what could impact the 2022 election
i'm on twitter at deepakman we'll take a
quick break and be right back